yeah it's sort of not how you treat
filmmakers and
stars and people who you know they these
guys have given a lot for these these
projects and
they deserved to be consulted and spoken
to about what was going to happen to
their work
that's christopher nolan candidly
addressing warner brothers decision to
release its 2021 slate of movies on hbo
max
the same day they hit theaters there's
such controversy around it because they
didn't tell anyone
in 2021 they've got some of the top
filmmakers in the world they've got some
of the biggest stars in the world
who have worked for years in some cases
on these
projects very close to their hearts that
are meant to be you know
big screen experiences they're meant to
be out there for the widest possible
audiences the sort of
a release and now they're being used as
a
lost leader for the streaming service
for the fledgling streaming service
um without any consultation or any so
yeah there's a lot of a lot of
controversy it's very very very very
messy
a real bait and switch the
oscar-nominated director is back at it
with his newest mind-bending thriller
tenet
starring john david washington both
nolan and washington
are thrilled at the film's success in
this most unusual era for movie goers
i mean with the benefit of hindsight it
was great to see
how audiences in places where the virus
had been managed
carefully and efficiently where they
could safely go back to movie theaters
people came back in in great numbers and
that was a wonderful thing to see for
the future of our business
obviously to not be able to travel the
world you know with everyone involved in
the film
and and have the premieres and
experience it with audiences
in you know japan or australia or
wherever um you know there's a source of
frustration and then to not really be
able to release the film in the united
states it's a
source of frustration but at the end of
the day 2020 has been a
a year of tremendous adversity for for
everybody on the planet and so
um you know we feel very lucky i feel
very lucky to have been working to be
engaged in
a creative pursuit i think it's been a
really fortunate thing for myself
i would echo that it was it was exciting
to know that
uh where it was safe where they had
managed it
uh places um they were able to see it
and uh the responses has been have been
great you know the feedback has been
uh very positive online and uh that you
know that makes me feel that makes you
feel good because you believe in
something you hope the people get to see
it
and then the time and the you know what
we're the the times we're living in
right now it's um
the fact that they still got to see it
in certain places it makes you feel good
about it
all i have for you is a word
tenant it'll open the right doors
some of the wrong ones too
i don't know if i have any advice but uh
i think it's a it's a great uh
opportunity to really um you know
maybe understand uh deeper the the
movements
you know the a lot of the action
sequences the fighting and
in the inverted punching and blocking
and all those kinds of things i think
to be able to see it you know come you
know in your own home and be
have the ability to rewind or pause uh
to really if you want like monday
morning quarterback or
enjoy the uh the fighting sequences of
the breakdown that that's
that's pretty cool i think to that
opportunity uh to do that i think is
pretty cool
yeah i think i think one of the most fun
things about revisiting a movie like
this is
seeing the work that you guys did the
actors did seeing i mean
with yourself a lot in the physicality
of it with with rob
you know a lot with robert pattinson is
in in the film there's a there's a lot
of layers to what he's doing that
you watch it again you see a very
different performance a second time
uh which is really fun and and yeah i
love
i love working on films where if you're
interested to watch it again
uh there's something else to be found
there it's really fun to watch people
interpret the work and you try and leave
some things open in there i mean
obviously we have our
version of what's going on and all the
rest but you kind of want to let the
work speak for itself and and
see what people uh what people come up
with but uh
yeah no spoilers please we're trying to
prevent world war iii
not saying are we getting here no
something worse you try and put
everything you can into the into the one
movie but you like to create a world
that lives on in the mind of the
audience
lives on in my mind all the rest
sometimes you're drawn to revisiting
that
uh sometimes you're not it really a lot
of it is is to do with
uh the audience response to do you know
it's it's up to the audience to tell us
what they make of it and and what
they're interested in
well how big a plane
that part is a little dramatic long
term um i think i think all the studios
know that uh
you know the movie theater experience
will bounce back and and
be a very important part of the
ecosystem long term
and so what you have right now in our
business is a lot of grappling
and the use of the pandemic as an excuse
for sort of grappling for short-term
advantage
and it's really unfortunate it's it's
not the way to do business and
it's it's not the best thing for the for
the health of our industry but
um you know when the theaters uh are
back
you know and people are going back to
the movies when the vaccines have been
rolled out and there's an appropriate
health response uh from the federal
government um you know
i'm i'm very bullish on the long-term
prospects of the industry people love
going to the movies and
they're going to get to uh to go again
you